Opposers,
here's a fun fact about me
that's also my Tinder bio:
I always win at board games.
I win at board games so much,
nobody will play with me.
What can I say?
I guess people just hate to see
a guy like me succeed.
Now, my strategy is simple:
I play smart.
Some might call it "cheating,"
but that's-that's just a word
losers use to make themselves
feel better.
So that's why I'm mad as hell
about a new edition
of my favorite board game
that just makes it harder
for winners to win.
Take a whiff.
REPORTER:
Are you a Monopoly cheater?
Well, then this newest version
of the game is for you.
Hasbro is releasing
a Cheaters Edition
of the game later this year.
The idea came
after a survey revealed
that over half
of Monopoly players
try to cheat during the game.
The new twist
on this beloved board game
comes complete with cheat cards,
free properties,
and even handcuffs attached
to the board
to keep those cheaters
chained to jail.
That's right.
They try to put you in cuffs
for a real estate crime.
And they say this game
is based in reality.
This new tabletop abomination
includes 15 cheat cards
that actually tell players
how to play smart.
Look, these cards are real.
There's Identity Theft that lets
you move another player's piece
instead of your own,
and Squatter's Rule
that lets you collect rent
from another player's property.
Hasbro, stop giving away
my moves!
Next, you're gonna tell my son
Alito how I always destroy him
at Connect Four.
It's easy.
I never taught him how to count.
But this new Cheaters Edition
is clearly trying to handicap
natural winners
by building our best sneaky
strategies into the game.
There goes the neighborhood.
In fact, there go
all the neighborhoods.
Boardwalk, Park Place,
Luxury Tax, Question Mark Land--
all of 'em.
Think about it:
if everybody's cheating,
then nobody's cheating.
And cheating is the entire
foundation of Monopoly.
It's right there in the origin
story. You guys know this.
Monopoly was invented in 1903
by Elizabeth Magie,
pictured here
on a counterfeit dime. Now...
this proto-Elizabeth Warren
created the game
to expose the evils
of capitalism.
But capitalism is flawless.
Here's proof: 30 years later,
an enterprising man stole
the idea for her game,
rebranded it,
and got rich off it.
And that's how you play
Monopoly!
(cheering and applause)
Do not pass Go. Do not collect
any money for your idea.
I get to be the car.
Yay, capitalism.
This Cheaters Edition
will do whatever it takes
to hobble winners. It even has
a tattle-tale feature.
REPORTER:
You report the cheater,
who's on your left or right,
to Mr. Monopoly
via Facebook Messenger,
and then he will chime in
to settle disputes
and crack down on rule-breaking
by handing out consequences
in real-time.
That's right.
Monopoly has
a special prosecutor now.
What's next, a district attorney
for Gumdrop Mountain?
A court stenographer
for Scrabble?
A building inspector for Jenga?
Sir, look, if you're gonna go
in there, don't go in there.
But if you do, just tap on it
with your index finger first.
I suspected
this Cheaters Monopoly was part
of a larger plot.
Some said I was paranoid.
But "paranoid" is just a fancy
word for "always right."
So I did some digging.
That's when I found an article,
and hidden below the headline
were dozens of smaller headlines
strung together
in sequential order.
It was baffling.
But I eventually found a quote
there from a Hasbro executive
admitting that the new version
will "level the playing field"
and make sure cheaters don't
have a "special advantage."
Level the playing field?
No special advantage?
This is not a drill.
-(siren wailing)
-MALE VOICE: Socialism alert!
Socialism alert!
-Socialism alert!
-Opposers,
it is time to focus up!
We cannot let socialism
invade Monopoly!
You can't run an electric
company from your spot
in the bread line!
This new Cheaters Edition
is simply un-American.
In this country, we reward
people who play smart.
It's why billionaires
get tax cuts
and why Republicans
control Congress
and why Merrick Garland
is currently bagging groceries
at a CVS somewhere.
There's nothing wrong
with playing smart.
Just listen to our president.
He didn't pay
any federal income tax,
-so if he's paid...
-That makes me smart.
Yeah.
It makes him smart.
Do you know how high
your IQ needs to be
for your businesses to weather
six bankruptcies?
Smart.
But everywhere you look,
deep-state forces are making it
harder to win unfair and square.
Check out Pennsylvania,
where the state supreme court
ruled against partisan
district maps.
Screw you, Pennsylvania!
And we can't sleep on Florida,
where a devious federal judge
says
they can't bar ex-felons
from voting.
That's gerrymandering
and voter suppression--
two of our smartest plays.
And it's only getting worse.
Last week,
I got maced in a Whole Foods
for sampling the grapes.
I mean, come on!
People, America
is all about playing smart.
It's who we are. We can't let
some globalist board game
or state supreme court
take that away from us.
Now, if you'll excuse me,
I got to pass Go and collect,
I don't know, let's say $700.